par les draquel garido mise en retrait 4
mois par la France insoumise euh
regardez est-ce qu'ils ont eu raison ou
pas 4 mois comme Adrien catn ouis ouais
pour des faits beaucoup plus graves et 4
mois prend 4 mois aussi Raquel alors que
était hors du groupe pas elle regardez
la conférence de presse de Mathilde
Panou c'est toujours une souffrance de
la regarder bah ça c'est vra il est faux
de dire que Madame garido aurait été
sanctionné pour avoir critiqué ou pour
avoir juste exprimé ses id
mais pour des accumulations d'agissement
et de propos répétés qui nuisent au bon
fonctionnement du groupe notamment je
vous relis ce que nous avons écrit la
diffusion de fausse information dans la
presse à propos du groupe ou de ses
membres la mise en cause et le
dénigrement annominem de plusieurs
membres du groupe la prise à partie de
salariés du groupe parlementaire voilà
donc ça n'a rien à voir avec le fait
d'avoir exprimé oui ou non des idées ou
des critiques voilà c'est toujours une
galère d'entendre math comprend rien de
ce qu'elle dit rien fris plus parce il a
fait un tweet en disant rquel garido est
en désaccord sur l'absence de démocratie
dans la France insoumise donc il dit que
le le propos même pour lequel on on va
la sanctionner c'est parce qu'elle est
en désaccord et comment notre mouvement
qui prône la 6e République lui répond
non par un débat mais par une sanction
alors garido est vénre verdict de la
Cour pénale des insoumis 4 mois 4 mois
cela vous dit quelque chose c'est comme
Adrien catnin pendant 4 mois je n'ai
plus le droit de représenter mon groupe
parlementaire en tant coratrice dans les
discussions générales en commission des
lois et dans l'hémicycle je n'ai plus le
droit de poser des questions au
gouvernement au nom de mon groupe je
suis mise au ban pourquoi parce que j'ai
tenu bon sur le principe de non cumulle
des Mandin parce que j'ai voulu que les
moyens du groupe parlementaire bon voilà
elle est bon elle elle estén à mon avis
elle reviendra plus mais il faut qu'elle
parte avec fin avec clémentineotin il
faut qu'il parte il faut la r parce que
là c'est un naufrage de l'autre que
c'est ils sont durs là écouter là que ce
soit Mélenchon mathde Panau toute
l'équipe là flemme la base PL ave madame
gar ouais flemme absolue les vrais
électeurs ouais ou en tous les cas c'est
un parti qui ne sait pas pr pas faire
preuve d'ouverture c'est le moins qu'on
pu puisse dire et moi je trouve que ça
ressemble à des procè staliniens c'est
tu n'es pas dans la ligne donc tu sors
c'est tout sauf ce que doit être un
parti politique où la contradiction doit
permettre de faire avancer les choses
non non merci non tu vas toujours voter
pour eux ou pas mais moi je suis pour la
sanction à GAE elle va pas te
lâcher est pour la San lui il est pour
la sanction bien sûr quoi mais bien sûr
pour la San j'ai relancé le
débat mais vraiment j'allais passer à un
autre sujet bravo passer à côté de ça
déjà tu déjà tu t'avances pas comme
ça excusez-moi je peux vous poser une
question bien sûr avec grand plaisir je
balance dans la presse je dis cyil
Hanouna ne fait que nuire à Touche pas à
mon poste c'est plus possible il y en a
marre et cetera je vais te dire je reste
ici c'est pas 4 mois que tu prends c'est
ans et ben merci quand vous balancez ça
sur votre patron Jean-Luc Mélenchon ne
fait que nuire vous ne pouvez pas rester
vous nêtes que sanctionné ce qui a tué
le Parti socialiste c'est les frondeur
donc Mélenchon ne veut pas de ça on peut
pas tolérer ça dans un parti vous êtes
dedans vous êtes dehors les gars moi je
peux plus donner mon
avisexemple il est mauvais plusieurs
fois tu t'embrouill ici avec des chron
ils ont quitté le plateau ça s
embrouillé en loge on s engueulé
plusieurs fois même moi oui
alors demain dans la presse dit c Hanoun
ne fait que nuir qu'est-ce que tu as dit
elle a dit jeanluc Mélenchon ne fait que
nu ne fait que nuir Touche pas à mon
poste depuis 10 mois mais sauf que c'est
pas vrai ouais
ou alors là vous vous VZ trouver un
argument biais tout c'est catastrophique
pour son parti pardon et même depuis des
anné tu peux pas transposer les choses
ça n'a rien à voir vous non plus là vous
ne savez plus quoi
répondre
excuseous tu compares Anouna à Mélenchon
ça n absolument aucun
rapport mais oui mais d'accord mais sauf
que a pas y a pas une
fractureex il y a pas une fracture entre
cyil Hanouna et nous alors que là il y a
une fracture au sein de la France
insoumise entre une petite partie parle
pas du fond je te parle du titre dans la
presse mais réfléchis ESS d'aller un peu
plus loin tu as fait ton numéro de
claquette là avec ton truc cétait si je
disais ce publiquement son patron fait
pasar j'ai une question à vous poser
facture nous ben non ben non voilà donc
c'est pas comparable c'est bien tu as
fait ton numéro de claquette mais ça
rien à voiras ton émission Cardo tuas
ton
émion tonmion tion
tmion tu dis ça pourquoi tu dis ça il
vous a bien défendu il aura une belle
émission bravo bravo bravo
Charles Charles pas trop Charles j'aV
envie d'appeler Charles car leconscient
euh on va passer à Ann hiidalgo après
les révélations sur son voyage en
Nouvelle-Calédonie et à Tahiti Ann
hiidalgo doit-elle démissionner puisque
c'est un voyage qui a coûté près de
60000 € la mère de Paris est rentré hier
et elle a enfin décidé de communiquer
sur ce voyage regardez on en parle
ensemble et énormément le temps demande
la démission d'algo Gil Verdez regardez
c'est un déplacement à près de 6000 €
qui embarrasse la mairie de Paris celui
d'an dalgo ces derniers jours en
Polynésie au programme rencontre des
élus locaux lutteent contre la montée
des eos et surtout visite du site
olympique des épreuves de surf pourtant
la mè de paris ne s'est pas rendu sur
les lieux et a poursuivi son voyage dans
les îles par une visite familiale
annidalgos autorise un voyage opaque à
Tahiti avec une délégation pléthorique
mais quel lien avec Paris et les
Parisiens je trouve qu'on fait vraiment
une polémique de tout et je pense que le
soufflet va assez vite retomber alors
est-ce que le soufflet va assez vite
retomber là je crois pas hein pas si
elle doit démissionner mais pour ne pas
démissionner à mon avis elle doit tout
rembourser dans ces cas-là pour moi
c'est la seule manière là elle a
remboursé le billet de retour il y a
confusion entre voyage officiel visite
privée pour moi dans ces cas-là vous
remboursez l'allée le retour les hôtels
sur place et tout sin 6000 boules non
c'est pour 6 ça part tout ça part pour
moi les autres il vont faire non les
autres ils étaient eux ils étaient pas
voyage privé elle a étéir sa fille elle
a pris des vacances pour voir sa fille
au terme du voyage officiel alors a le
communiqué de par depuis quelques jours
ce déplacement sucite une attention
particulière les parisiennes et les
Parisiens ont le droit de disposer
d'information fiaable factuell et
transparente à son sujet coup du
déplacement
40955 € de transport pour 6 personnes
18545 € de frais d'hébergement et de
restauration ce qui nous fait donc 6000
€ la mre de Paris voilà le coût du
transport de l'ensemble de la
déléglation des trois élus et de trois
collaborateurs qui les accompagnent s
établi pour l'ensemble des vols Paris
Nea et les frais d'hébergement voilà
donc ils ont ils ont communiqué mais
qu'est-ce que à quoi ça 25 versions
différentes et puis Cyril dans le
communiqué qui qui est très mal rédigé à
un moment on voit comme justification
délirante paris est une ville
ultramarine elle rassemble une
population très nombreuse venant de tous
les départements et territoire d'outrem
les 53 agents de la Ville de Paris plus
de 6000 d'entre eux sont originaires des
Outremers mais quel est le rapport mais
c'est une Dar c'est une énorme Dara on
dirait on dirait un enfant que tu
surprends avec le doigt dans le pot de
confiture c'est elle a changé 12 fois de
version euh non elle s'est fait cramer
demande aussi ce qu'elle a essayé de
faire aussi parce que quand elle était
là-bas elle publiait des photos de Paris
alors qu'elle était là-bas donc on se
dit est-ce qu'elle a essayé de cacher
quelque chose surtout la communication
finale qui est de dire qu'elle Pera la
moitié parce que donc c'est à moitié un
vis un voyage privé ça ne cache pas le
fait queelle n'y serait pas allée si sa
filleille n'avait pas été expatrié
là-bas aurait pas habillé tout ça de
propos le sondage oui 91 % doit-elle
démissionner oui à 9 % c'est qu'elle a
réussi à êtreélu he c'est fou 91 %m
c'est championne des voyages elle a
quand même fait une vingtaine de voyages
depuis à l'étranger depuis qu'elle a été
élue donc quelqu'un qui est très
écologiste et qui se dit voilà très
c'est la confusion argent public argent
privé ça les Français supportent pas
alle